Puerto Rico is acknowledging for the
first time the death toll from Hurricane
Maria is likely more than 22 times
higher than the US territories previous
estimates officials now say more than
1400 deaths are blamed on the
catastrophic storm the last official
death count was 64
David beg no is back in Puerto Rico
David good morning I can tell you from
spending the last many months on the
island glad doing reports here it is so
important to the people of Puerto Rico
to get a final number and this is not
final but it is important the figure
comes from the government's own
mortality data that journalists had to
sue to get and even when the numbers
were released the government didn't make
an official acknowledgement until they
just sent this report to Congress asking
for money it has been nearly eleven
months since Hurricane Maria devastated
the island of Puerto Rico and the exact
death toll is still unclear in a report
to Congress requesting 139 billion
dollars in aid money the government of
Puerto Rico acknowledged that in the
four months following the hurricane 1427
more people died than normal compared to
the previous four years baby we've
always said that the mum was gonna be
higher Hector pisghetti's Puerto Rico's
Secretary of Public Safety we never
heard you come out and say 1427 until
you put this report to Congress but it
was never maybe maybe they said it's an
issue of perception maybe but it was
never meant to be secret it wasn't
secret this is what the recovery report
says a study done by Harvard University
estimated the death toll after Hurricane
Maria to be between eight hundred and
eight thousand a report out last week
conducted by Penn State University put
the number as high as 1139 the Puerto
Rico government is waiting on a report
it commissioned from George Washington
University Ricardo Rose say yo he's
Puerto Rico's governor you paid $300,000
to George Washington University for the
study right you've already said you
didn't have a right protocol in place to
get the accurate death toll nobody
believes 64 I know you don't even
believe it well it's not even
not about believing it is just yeah if
people say it's the official counter it
really it's just really the count that's
where the counts stopped its words stop
oh no you realize that it wasn't
appropriate my sources are telling me
that the George Washington University
study should be released by the end of
the month Gail before we toss it back
we're at the Forensic Sciences Center
we've talked about a backlog of bodies
there are nearly 300 that are awaiting
autopsy some of them are being stored in
those trailers the US government is
sending pathologist to now help process
that backlog we're told it should get
better soon meantime the pain continues
there thank you very much David Berg now
in Puerto Rico